cette proposition de loi elle a été
pensée pour améliorer tout simplement
l'accès aux soins de nos concitoyens la
baisse de la démographie médicale est
identifiée depuis très longtemps dans
notre pays il y a 10 ans c'était déjà
des inquiétudes donc il était temps de
faire un pas pour améliorer cette prise
en charge de nos concitoyens parce que
trop de Français ont pas de médecin
traitant aujourd'hui
tous les territoires sont concernés les
territoires
urbains les territoires ruraux
évidemment un peu plus c'était
territoires ruraux il est important de
faire un pas et cet effort on demande
aujourd'hui avec cette proposition de
loi nous interdits en médecine générale
à qui on va demander de faire un an de
plus un an d'internat cette année
d'internat est consacré à un stage qu'on
appelle en ambulatoire c'est à dire en
médecine de ville et en autonomie
supervisée ça veut dire que ils iront
faire un stage au côté d'un médecin qui
sera maître de stage c'est-à-dire qu'ils
n'auront pas tout seul au milieu de
nulle part exercer la médecine
évidemment ils seront encadrés c'est une
allée de professionnalisation ça va
permettre deux choses deux choses
importantes démystifier à la fois ce
qu'est l'installation d'un médecin en
libéral et puis démystifier ce que sont
les territoires soudain c'est-à-dire les
territoires où nous n'avons pas assez de
médecins généralistes ce sont pas
forcément des déserts il y a une vie
dans ces territoires il y a d'autres
professionnels de santé qui existent et
je crois que en allant faire un an de
stage bien encadré dans des cabinets
médicaux des maisons de santé où ils
seront bien accueillis leur permettra de
de mieux appréhender ce qui est
l'exercice de médecin généraliste au
sein d'un cabinet médical et dans des
territoires où il y a des besoins il y a
des patients qui n'ont pas de médecin
traitant je pense que c'est important
d'y répondre
[Musique]
et puis des années les élus qui font
tout ce qui peuvent pour rendre leur
territoire attractif qui ont fait
beaucoup d'efforts d'investissement
notamment dans des maisons de santé ou
en rachetant des cabinets médicaux pour
que les médecins qui les médecins qui
souhaiteraient s'installer dans leur
dans leur commune et les meilleures
conditions j'allais dire pratiques pour
exercer bien maintenant devant
effectivement aux internes de faire un
pas c'est vrai que on leur demande une
année de plus
d'internatives général il faut pas que
ce soit les seuls à faire ce pas les
élus ont fait beaucoup d'efforts on
demande aujourd'hui aux étudiants de
faire un effort c'est aussi un pas qu'on
demande aux médecins généralistes
installé parce qu'il ne faudra plus se
mettre de stage universitaire donc les
médecins généralistes sont invités à
s'engager pour accueillir des internes
des accueillir évidemment dans les
meilleures conditions possibles et puis
aussi peut-être un pas faire pour les
facultés de médecine qui au lieu
d'organiser les formations pour que les
médecins généralistes deviennent être de
stage universitaire et bien plus
s'organiser ces formations pas seulement
à la Faculté mais aussi dans les
départements qui dépendent du ressort de
la faculté et au plus près du lieu
d'exercice des médecins généralistes
installés je crois que voilà il faut que
chacun fasse un pas pour que demain il y
a une meilleure réponse en terme de
prise en charge des accessoires pour nos
concitoyens
[Musique]
nous demandons un effort aux intermites
faire une quatrième année nous leur
demandons de faire un pas pour un
meilleur axe soin de la part de nos
concitoyens j'attends également du
ministère qu'il fasse également un
effort en termes de reconnaissance en
termes de rémunération financière pour
ses futurs médecins je crois que ça
serait un signe fort important
indispensable pour que cette proposition
loi devienne une loi et qu'elle soit une
réussite pour tous les Français
[Musique]